that's me assaulted what really shocks
and astonishes me is how the people
around you suddenly turn their backs on
you you might be a hero when the
investors come but when all comes to an
end and this really surprised me friends
who I've known long before cars app was
founded just weren't my friends anymore
also gives me the flying shaft economics
engineer Oliver lunch debt founded a
startup that left him broke he invented
a digital key that unlocks cars using a
smartphone app a device could be fitted
on most common vehicles he received
numerous awards for his innovation but
after four years the funding was gone
the experience has scarred him as well
it was a pretty big shock one Friday
evening in November we found out that an
expected investment just wasn't coming
it was already in the bag the contracts
had already been negotiated but someone
just spontaneously changed their mind so
we suddenly started trying to get the
funding some other way as fast as
possible Titan Omaha get super common
he'd already burned through one and a
half million euros money from server
operators investors and acquaintances he
had to lay off 10 employees failures are
hardly ever spoken of affairs for
company founders these are places of
boundless optimism even though 9 out of
10 startups in Germany flounder people
in Oliver's position usually keep quiet
but he was open and honest about his
defeat he had industrially should have
released the product earlier and adapted
it better to the customers needs we
spent too long developing it in the
wrong direction it was too late before
we discovered our niche and that we
should turn around and change our
strategy nexans Lloyd tibia slim boot
has two failures behind him but that
hasn't put people off him in the
business world
manacle my clients respect what I know
and they don't see it as a stigma or a
minus point stick my oldest models so is
this fear that people talk about
unfounded important and but I in the
professional field at unfounded in
society well I often get asked by
friends and family how I can advise
other people when I failed myself my
company failed so it's not right for me
to advise other companies but it is
right it works well experiences like
these can make young people afraid of
starting their own businesses yeah those
failure probably isn't such a bad thing
starting out takes the most courage
after that you can see how it goes and
embark on something new it's not a bad
thing these people survived and they're
still happy wasn't opens new Bristol
finish up dolls Uganda's I learned that
I don't take enough risks when it comes
to money I try to borrow as little as
possible a temp capitata officer if
there's a will if you fight for an idea
and show your perseverance you can
achieve a lot come on people being
Oliver lynched act has since founded a
new company this time digitally opening
of his doors his new venture was
developed in a Berlin startup center
financed in part from his mother savings
he pays three hundred and fifty euros
rent a month here the budgets tight but
it meant turning a profit right from the
start this gets us and let us view
that's the first time that I can really
sleep soundly at night we can finally
stop worrying where the money's coming
from in two or three months for the rent
the staff their salaries it's much more
relaxed Wolfen boy dick and slander he
already has his eyes on the adjacent
room in order to grow his business and
he plans to hire three more people his
clients now include a car rental firm
and germany's biggest telecommunications
provider deutsche telekom although he'll
never completely forget his brush with
bankruptcy his dream of running a
successful business is finally becoming
a reality
you